if your day at work is anything like
mine you may think that accomplishing a
task is just a straight line from step
one to step two to step three but that's
not reality what actually happens is
that each step requires several tasks
such as sending an email updating a
spreadsheet attending a Web Conference
searching a
database the good news is that with AI
and automation a lot of these tasks can
be handed off to an AI assistant acting
on your behalf to get the work done
that's what Watson X orchestrate does it
coordinates the execution of predefined
skills through a natural language
interface here you see how you interact
through natural language to invoke
skills that are available to you for the
applications you use today so let's talk
about the bigger picture how to use Ai
and automation to get your work done
well we do it through what we call
skills a skill is a predefined
microautomation around a specific
application that you might use during
your workday so for instance if you're a
seller maybe you use Salesforce and you
could have a Salesforce skill that goes
out and finds a specific opportunity for
you you might have another skill that
goes and creates content for you using
generative Ai and then another skill
that's using Outlook to create an email
and send it out for you so we interact
with these skills through natural
language to orchestrate the work to be
done
and we can also Define skill flows which
Stitch the skills together in a
predefined way with outputs pleading in
as inputs into to the next skills in the
flow so now you see how you can
orchestrate your work to get from due to
done so here's the homepage the chat
interface is where I initiate the work
to be done below the chat interface I
see lots of skills I can use some are
task specific skills like the ones here
to generate content another to send an
email or another to fetch the latest
opportunities I also have a skill flow
that stitches together all three skills
in the correct
order so let's get
going as I start typing my request
orchestrate recognizes terms I'm using
that match my available skill flow
saving me time right from the start when
more information is needed I'm queried
just for that
information all along the way I'm
involved only when needed I select the
opportunity I want to use and because I
invoked a skill flow the next skill is
automatically triggered as you can see
the output from the previous skill is
the input to generate the offer content
I don't have to provide this information
but I can refine the input and add a
discount the final skill in the flow is
the email skill and look at that you can
see that the info from the previous
skills is already filled in and I can
make changes before triggering the email
to be set I remain in
control I found a great opportunity
created offer content and sent the email
all from within orchestrate using skills
and a skill
flow but what if you use other
applications as you can see there are
several apps listed in the skills
catalog and if you don't see an
application that you use today you can
create new skills for any third party
app or homegrown applications using
available
apis or you can discover and create
skills from your existing automation
let's face it there's always more work
to do but you have the choice of how
it's done with automation you can
offload work to an AI assistant and get
more time back in your day thanks for
watching please remember to like And
subscribe